so what I said so far doesn't guarantee
anything about the existence of limit
where Newton's contant is actually
Infinity but nevertheless that limit may
exist if that limit exists that limit
the limiting theory is a theory in 11
dimensions it'll be a supermmetric
relativistic theory in 11 dimensions
with 11 dimensional supergravity is slow
energy limit and depending on no
dimensionless parameters does it exist I
haven't the faintest
idea
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans Science
CC la théorie
M on c aujourd'hui d'écrire notre
univers avec deux grande théorie la
relativité générale qui modélise la
gravité à grande échelle par un espace
en courbé et le modèle standard des
particules qui unifie toutes les autres
interactions par des champs quantiques
dont les vibrations peuvent être
interprétés comme des
particules par essence ces deux modèles
sont assez similaires tous deux exploite
le concept de champ le champ de courbure
de l'espace-temp pour la relativité
générale et les champs quantiques des
particules pour le modèle
standard mais tandis que la relativité
est une théorie classique qui prédit une
évolution précise au cours du temps le
modèle standard est quantique il décrit
le monde à travers des superpositions et
des
probabilités ces deux théories décrivent
donc deux univers complètement
différents à grande échelle la
relativité générale est une excellente
description de notre univers mais
lorsqu'on zoome dans la matière il faut
prendre en compte les phénomènes de la
physique
quantique jusqu'ici ce n'est pas un
problème on peut décrire les
perturbations dans la courbure de
l'espace-temp comme un champ quantique
dont les fluctuations peuvent être vues
comme des particules les gravitons on
détermine ainsi le comportement
quantique de la
gravité mais si l'on zoome à des
échelles ridiculement petites en dessous
d'un quintilllionième de micromètre sous
l'échelle de planque les calculs
n'aboutissent plus à cette échelle
fondamentale la gravité ne semble plus
compatible avec le monde
quantique comment les réconcilier
comment comprendre ce qui se passe là où
la gravité agit à l'échelle fondamentale
comme au centre des trous noirs ou lors
des premiers instants du Big Bang dans
cette vidéo nous allons nous immerger
dans le monde abstrait de la physique
théorique à la recherche d'un candidat
prometteur pour résoudre ce problème la
théorie
M attention ce sujet est
particulièrement abstrait et il est
préférable d'avoir visionné auparavant
la vidéo sur la théorie des des
[Musique]
cordes nous sommes dans les années 1970
et les chercheurs s'intéressent à une
théorie prometteuse la super gravité
notre espace-temp possède quatre
symétries les lois de la physique
restent les mêmes après translation
rotation écoulement du temps et
changement de
référentiel ces quatre symétries sont
mathématiquement incluse dans la
relativité
générale mais il pourrait exister une
autre symétrie encore hypothétique qu'on
appelle la super
symétrie si on inclut également cette
symétrie on obtient la super
gravité par essence la super graravité
est très similaire à la relativité
l'espace-temps peut s'y courber
engendrer des structures intéressantes
et même produire des singularités sans
dimension formant des trous
noirs mais les physiciens s'amusent à
l'explorer dans des univers
hypothétiques avec davantage de
dimensions et la théorie prédit alors
des généralisations de trous noir à une
deux ou plus de dimensions formant des
objets étendus des membranes ou brânes
pour faire plus court
elles peuvent posséder une masse une
charge et même être super
symétrique le modèle est intéressant
mais encore une fois lorsqu'on zoome
sous les de planque la théorie ne
fonctionne plus comme pour la relativité
la super gravité n'aboutit pas à
l'échelle
[Musique]
fondamentale quelques années plus tard
toutefois dans les années 1980 les
physiciens découvrent un nouveau modèle
révolutionnaire il suppose que toutes
les particules sont constituées d'un
petit brin d'énergie en vibration une
corde exploitant lui aussi le concept de
su syymétrie on le baptise théorie des
supercordes lorsqu'elles se rencontrent
les cordes peuvent interagir les unes
avec les autres se combiner ou se
diviser et comme des cordes de Guitar
elles peuvent vibrer de différentes
façons se comportant à notre échelle
comme différentes
particules on découvre alors avec
stupeur que l'un de ces modes de
vibration se comporte exactement comme
le gravit
cette théorie permet pour la première
fois de décrire la gravité quantique de
façon
[Musique]
fondamentale le modèle est prometteur
mais il fixe des restrictions sur
l'univers la théorie impose par exemple
que l'espace-temps possède non pas qu
mais 10 dimensions avec six dimensions
spatiales supplémentaires que l'on
aurait encore jamais
détecté la théorie fixe également les
types de cordes que l'on peut étudier si
l'on décide d'étudier des cordes
ouvertes par exemple des filaments
celles-ci peuvent se refermer sur
elles-même et il faut donc aussi étudier
des cordes fermé des
boucles en prenant en compte ces
restrictions les chercheurs découvrent
que la théorie des supercordes
n'autorise que cinq possibilités
d'univers le type 1 qui contient des
cordes ouvertes et
fermées les types 2A et 2B qui
contiennent des cordes fermés et deux
types hétérotiques so32 et E8 C E8 qui
contiennent des cordes fermés avec des
vibrations différentes se déplaçant en
sens opposé ces C modèles sont les
seules déclinaisons possibles pour
espérer d'écrire notre univers avec des
super
cordes mais alors dans laquelle de ces
cinq versions vivons-nous laquelle
décrit réellement notre
[Musique]
monde laissons cette question de côté et
reprenons la super
gravité
[Musique]
à ce stade on pourrait penser que la
théorie des super cordes et la super
gravité sont deux descriptions
complètement distinctes mais il existe
en fait un lien intime entre ces deux
théorie à grande échelle toutes deux
décrivent un univers super symétrique
avec de la gravité et pour cause la
super gravité si on l'applique à un
univers à 10 dimensions s'avère être une
approximation de la th des
supercordes en particulier ceci implique
que les brânes de la super graravité
existent également dans le monde des
cordes les cordes sont justement l'un
des types de Brân poss possible à une
dimension mais il existe aussi des
dbrânes sur lesquelles peuvent se fixer
des cordes ouvertes ou encore des brânes
NS5 à 5
dimensions le modèle de la super gravité
est donc encore utile et les chercheurs
lui découvrent une autre propriété
inattendue la supergravité a une limite
elle accepte un nombre maximal de 11
dimensions une de plus que dans la
théorie des
supercordes dans ce modèle de super
graravité à 11 dimensions toutes les
constantes de l'univers seraient alors
fixées par les
mathématiques contrairement aux cinq
déclinaison de la théorie des
supercordes la supergravité nous propose
une nouvelle théorie unique pour décrire
le monde avec 11 dimensions du moins en
[Musique]
approximation pour résumer au début des
années 1990 les théoriciens disposent
d'un panel de 6 modèles mathématiques
intéressants les cinq versions de la
théorie des supercordes à 10 dimensions
et la super gravité à 11 dimensions mais
plusieurs chercheurs et en particulier
Edward whton vont peu à peu découvrir un
réseau de connexion subtile des dualités
qui relient toutes ces théories les unes
aux
autres les physiciens commencent par se
pencher sur la super graravité à 11
dimensions ce modèle contient entre
autres des brânes à deux dimensions des
surfaces mais imaginons que l'on
transforme l'une des 11 dimensions en un
cercle et qu'on la réduise jusqu'à ne
plus
l'avoir après cette compactification il
ne reste plus que 10 dimensions et les
brânes ont perdu une dimension devenant
des
cordes de façon surprenante le modèle
qu'on obtient se comporte comme la
théorie des supercordes ou plus
précisément comme sa version
2A avant la découverte de cette dualité
les chercheurs ne pouvaient étudier la
théorie 2A qu'avec des cordes
interagissant faiblement les unes avec
les autres en effet l'approche utilisée
pour calculer leur comportement dite
perturbative consiste à prendre une
première estimation et à lui ajouter des
petites corrections pour prendre en
compte les interactions de plus en plus
précisément mais si les cordes
interagissent fortement ces corrections
sont trop grandes elles ne permettent
pas d'affiner le résultat et même avec
un nombre infini d'entre elles on ne
pourrait pas décrire certains
phénomènes toutefois la découverte de ce
lien entre les deux théories va
justement permettre de sonder le
comportement de ces cordes à fortes
Inter action pour se faire il suffit de
reformer la 11e dimension que l'on avait
compactifié en un cercle en ajoutant
cette dimension on parvient à décrire
l'univers de la théorie 2A mais cette
fois-ci pour des cordes interagissant
fortement pour décrire ce régime il faut
donc une 11e
dimension de façon similaire on peut
compactifier la 11e dimension en un
segment plutôt qu'un
cercle obtient cette fois une
description de la théorie htérotique E8
cro E8 et là encore le lien entre les
deux modèles permet aux physicien de
sonder le comportement de cordes à
fortes interactions pour lesquelles les
calculs étaient auparavant
impossibles peu à peu les chercheurs
découvrent davantage de dualités en
prenant les théories 2A et 2B par
exemple et en les compactifiant chacune
sur un cercle l'un grand l'autre petit
on obtient deux modèles différents mais
qui s'avèrent équivalent ils décrivent
un même univers de deux façons
différentes chaque grandeur dans l'un
est relié à une grandeur dans l'autre
par exemple la vitesse d'une corde se
déplaçant dans la dimension compacte
correspond au nombre de fois où elle
s'enroule autour de cette dimension dans
l'autre
description on parle de dualité t elle
relie aussi les deux théories
hétérotiques entre
elles on découvre également la du s
selon laquelle certains modèles sont
équivalents lorsque les interactions
sont faibles dans l'un et fortes dans
l'autre nous avons déjà vu deux exemples
de cette dualité avec la super gravité à
11 dimensions qui permet de sonder des
phénomènes de fortes interactions au
sein de deux des théories des
supercordes mais cette dualité
s'applique également au type 1 et so32
ou plus intéressant encore à la théorie
2B avec elle-même lorsqu'on inverse
l'intensité des interactions les types
de Bran contenus dans la théorie se
convertissent les uns en les autres de
façon cohérente de sorte que l'on
retrouve le même modèle qu'au
[Musique]
départ en seulement quelques années les
chercheurs découvrent de nombreuses
dualités qui relie toutes ces théories
les unes avec les autres il s'agit de la
seconde révolution des supercordes grâce
à ces dualités des calcul fastidieux
dans un modèle peuvent devenir plus
simples dans un autre
modèle cette découverte permet d'étudier
des phénomènes jusqu'à l'ORS
inaccessibles et l'on réalise par
exemple que l'entropie des trous noirs
la quantité d'information qu'ils
contiennent peut se calculer en comptant
les cordes qui leur sont
attachées les résultats sont en parfait
accord avec les formules du rayonnement
de
Hawking cet élan de recherche mènera
également à la découverte d'une autre
dualité fascinante la correspondance ADS
cft selon laquelle certains univers
peuvent être décrits comme les
hologrammes de leur
[Musique]
surface en 1995 whton propose qu'il
pourrait exister une théorie unique et
fondamentale dont les cinq versions des
super cordes et la super gravité à 11
dimensions ne seraient que des
approximations un peu comme des
cartographies d'un paysage encore
méconnu ces six théories seraient des
descriptions partielles dans telle ou
telle condition et les dualités qui les
relient indiqueraient qu'elle se
recouvre par endroit pour décrire de
même
zone Witon baptise ce modèle la théorie
M1 un nom mystérieux pour une théorie
tout autant mystérieuse membrane ou
encore matrice il laisse la liberté aux
futurs chercheurs qui la comprendront
mieux dans choisir la
signification à grande échelle et pour
de faies interactions la théorie M
décrirait un monde super symétrique à 11
dimensions contenant des
brânes mais à l'échelle fondamentale
bien que tout semble indiquer qu'elle
existe son formalisme reste un mystère
elle pourrait s'avérer être une
description complètement inédite de
l'univers il existe déjà des tentatives
pour la formaliser comme le modèle
matriciel bfss selon lequel l'espace
temp et les cordes émergeraient d'une
description purement abstraite mais les
recherches dans ce domaine s'avèrent
très complexe à l'heure actuelle comme
pour toutes les théories qui tentent
d'unifier la gravité et le monde
quantique la théorie M n'est soutenue
par aucune preuve
expérimentale comme d'autres théories
elle accepte une large variété de
configurations initiales avec des
contenus et des géométries
d'espace-temps différentes et nous ne
savons pas encore laquelle correspond à
notre univers de même que nous ne
pouvons pas sonder la géométrie de
l'espace-temps à très grande échelle
nous ne pouvons pas non plus la sonder à
l'échelle fondamentale pour le
moment la théorie M reste toutefois la
principale candidate dans la recherche
d'une théorie du tout unifiant la
gravité et les particules du modèle
standard pour de nombreux chercheurs il
s'agit d'une théorie élégante et
prometteuse qui prédit par exemple
l'existence de la gravité sans qu'on a à
l'ajouter au modèle ces dernières
décennies ces recherches ont eu de
nombreuses retombées en physique et en
mathématiques en parallèle de nombreuses
autres théories furent développées comme
la gravité quantique à boucle la
triangulation dynamique causale ou
encore la sécurité asymptotique tentant
elles aussi d'unifier la gravité et le
monde
quantique lequel de ces modèles nous
permettra de comprendre un jour les
fondements de notre
univers qui sait peut-être queeux aussi
se complémenteront vers une théorie
encore plus
générale
[Musique]